joining us in the studio ian murray
shadow secretary of state for scotland
ms murray good to see you this morning
um well let's start with the northern
ireland protocol according to to jacob
rees-mogg you know we didn't see these
problems coming there's scope within uh
the agreement to renegotiate i mean on
that he's got a point doesn't he well
everyone did see this coming because
they said it was an oven ready deal and
we said if you put a border in the irish
they'll be inevitably problems because
the border between the great britain the
united kingdom and the eu is in ireland
now and and that was always going to
cause
difficulties but to rip up something
that they signed only a couple of years
ago or to threaten to rip up it's not
really resolving the problem and as
kirsten has consistently said yes they
went down the route of getting brexit
done but they've got to try and make
brexit work and it doesn't look as if
they're willing to do so but the
european union could unilaterally decide
not to insist on checks on everything
that's going across at the irc couldn't
they well they've offered various
solutions already including on
veterinary passports which the
government are seemingly rejecting so
there are things on the table this has
to happen through negotiation our
relationship post european union
membership was never going to be a
simple straightforward one because
nobody had done this before and
therefore it takes two parties to come
together to negotiate at what should be
a relatively simple negotiation because
both both parties are in roughly the
same place in terms of wanting trade to
happen but just specifically mr
rees-mogg is correct when he says that
there is scope in what was agreed back
in 2019 for aspects to be renegotiated
well let's have it done then let's get
the european union and the uk government
together but it seems to me that this
current government and we're interested
in picking fights with the eu rather
than trying to resolve it and the only
thing only people that suffer here are
the people of northern ireland because
they're in a situation now where they're
stuck with this border in the iric a uk
government and threatening the eu with
ripping up the protocol and the eu
threatening our trade work can you
imagine what would happen to the cost of
living crisis in northern ireland had we
ended up in a trade war with the
european union let's get both uh parties
round the table and let's get this
resolved so you presumably then think
that sir jeffrey donaldson head of the
yeah the big big obviously big figure in
northern irish politics but in his role
within the tup you think he's acting
entirely properly and you know
essentially holding installment to
ransom until he gets what he wants on
the protocol well the good friday
agreement lays out the processes for
setting up a power sharing agreement
pretty clearly and that is that the
first minister of northern ireland comes
from the party who wins the most seats
and there has to be a per share in
agreement for all the communities
represented in northern ireland and
that's what should happen everyone
should do this but if but it's not so do
you agree with it that do you agree with
what sir jeffrey is doing no absolutely
not i mean it's quite clear that the
power sharing agreement has to be put in
place the good friday agreement is clear
about what should happen that is endured
now since it was signed back in the
mid-1990s so therefore that has to be
followed through we want to see all
communities represented in a persian
agreement wants torment to work and that
has to come together to hold any sight
to ransom in these kinds of talks it
just makes things much more difficult
people have to come together and find
solutions to these issues
the problem is is that we have had
decade after decade of suggesting that
people need to come together in northern
ireland we we had a functioning
installment for for a good length of
time it's difficult to see a way back to
having a functional uh having a
functional installment of a functional
northern ireland assembly absent the
government
doing the unthinkable you know in your
mind and actually sorting out the
problems that there are with the
protocol in the short-term future it's
not going to happen but that has to
happen that's the only option that's on
the table because the good friday
agreement sets out quite clearly both
the legal and political and
constitutional ways in which northern
ireland assembly it comes together
that's now not happening because one
party to that agreement's decided not to
play ball now we've got the election of
speaker today we'll see whether or not
the dup actually vote for that speaker
from sir jeffrey this morning that they
will not be well if they don't
participate then the northern ireland
assembly therefore can't progress in the
way in which it should and therefore
we'll be in back in another election
again the people of northern ireland
have voted that's the way they have
voted we should respect that and the key
thing about the good friday agreement is
all communities have to be represented
in storm and that's the way it has to
work in order to keep those voices
together to keep peace in northern
ireland and to keep northern ireland
functioning as a democratic party
democratic state house sanguine how
comfortable are you with sinn fein that
a nationalist party a party that overtly
wants to see the reunification of
ireland is the largest party installment
right now well that's what the people of
northern ireland have voted for we need
to respect
that vote yeah but you can tell me how
otherwise you feel about it well i think
we're all uncomfortable with the
situation in northern ireland in terms
of what's happening with the protocol in
terms of what's happening with the
standoff
that's threatening the good friday
agreement everyone said and there'll be
column inches the the the length of
northern ireland and broadcast packages
um out there that shows that everyone
said that what was being proposed in
terms of the protocol may threaten the
good friday agreement now what we're
seeing now is a good friday agreement
being challenged because those steps to
put in place of government are not being
followed through
and therefore everything that was said
about the good federal government and
now seems to be coming to pass it's
really incumbent on the parties in
northern ireland and the uk government
to come together and resolve these
problems what about the big kind of
government announcement actually
pre-announcement would be better given
there aren't very very many details
about it that we will within a couple of
years see a fifth of the civil service
axed what's your view
well this has come out of nowhere the
prime minister challenged his cabinet to
come up with
ideas to deal with the cost of living
crisis it seems the only things they can
come up with is
emoting your car once every two years or
buying the cheap brand foods and
supermarkets refer to the government
this was in the spending review in 2021
but it was half the amount that they
were going for i think it was 45 000
they were looking for back then so it
has been around they've just doubled but
it'll take a long time obviously for
that to feed through and i think the
civil service union's absolutely correct
the government going to have to explain
what the government will no longer do
and you don't have to look very far to
see there's huge problems in the
passport office every mp's inbox will be
full of that at the moment the dvla has
huge problems there's problems in the
home office a person visa and asylum
applications every single department has
huge pressures on it so they'll have to
explain what this means and what it
would mean for government in this video
basically they say 38 000 leave the
civil service every year that plus a you
know a hiring freeze
job done
yes but there's still a consequence of
what the government has to be able to
achieve and has to be able to do you
can't just look at this as a number and
say well the government will stop doing
x y and z they have to lay out what that
actually means and don't forget it is
saving three and a half billion pounds
according to the government's figures
but they're wasting 4.3 billion pounds
on writing off in fraud there was tens
of billions wasted in terms of covert
and ppe contracts so this is a
government of wastage and now they're
turning to the civil service who keep
the government uh operating to say that
they're going to take the take the hits
three and a half billion pounds i mean
it's a lot of money and well rachel
reeves the shadow chancellor's set out
that a future labour government would
have an office of value for money and
look at every single penny of government
spending to make sure it's efficient and
make sure it's doing what it needs to do
in terms of delivering for the public
that's a very key policy of a future
labour government but it seems to me
that this government at this moment are
just flailing around looking for
anything to
try and resolve the cost of living
crisis and frankly the bottom line of
all that is they're doing very little
and people are seeing those huge bills
they're seeing a massive tax hike from
this government and they're wondering
what the government are going to do to
try and help them pay their bills just
before we let you go just a word on uh
evgeny lebedev or lord levidev as i
should call him despite the instruction
from the house of commons the government
is not going to be releasing that
information
what can the house of commons do about
that
well parliament has voted for that
information to be released and the
government are refusing to release it
this is admired and a whole host of
cronyism and the public will be cynical
about why the government aren't
releasing that information when the
parliament has voted for it to be
released this is a huge issue in terms
of the credibility of the prime minister
he had national security advice upon
lord
well we'll just need to bring it back to
parliament we will vote again to try and
get this um
information released and i think maybe
the speaker of the house of commons
should take a role here and say to the
government luke there's been a vote a
democratic vote in parliament you've
been asked to do something you're not
doing it the public will come to the
conclusion if they won't give us this
information and release this information
then they've got something to hide we
quite clearly think there is something
to hide and the public deserve the truth
yeah i suspect the speaker may well be
getting dragged into this a little bit
later on today um ian murray great to
have you in the studio thanks for being
with us